can you please be my duck friend and
don't scratch my eye out please duck hi
everyone my name is Tamra chambers and
this hat doesn't really fit over this
wig very well and this is Tamra Jessa
tonight I wouldn't serve captain Martha
I've been on the internet very limited
ly in the last two months and so I
missed that there was some weird drama
about Captain Marvel I generally don't
watch reviews before filming these
because I don't want to sound like I'm
trying to say what others are saying but
I went into this just wondering what the
hullabaloo was about so I watched a
couple and that were generally pretty
disappointed with the film and I went in
thinking that I was not going to enjoy
this film and I want just to be very
clear that I went into this movie
looking for flaws really really looking
for flaws with an evil eye I wanted this
to be a very honest reaction so with
that being said Captain Marvel was
awesome
definite flaws in this movie and some
dragging points for sure overall I'm
gonna be honest I think that I really
really just enjoy watching somebody that
I identify with kick-ass it was really
exciting having seen the trailers before
going into this I really really really
was not like dazzled by the trailers
like when I see a lot of these Marvel
trailers I get pumped and this didn't do
that for me honestly I really think it
was brie Larson in the trailers I
personally thought that she was a little
have the word I want to use this week
maybe that like her voice was kind of
weak it didn't like it didn't sound like
a superhero voice didn't sell like
Captain Marvel's voice and I don't know
it just it all seemed really kind of
just lackluster in the trailers she was
such a badass in the movie
less fighting wise and like superhero
kick your butt wise and more just I
think she fit the role more than I ever
thought that she did in the trailers
there's a lot of story being told here
they really jammed everything - Captain
Marvel in this one movie which was a
weird choice because yeah we've been
over a span of 10 years developing the
Marvel Universe and for them to choose
to make Captain Marvel this like good
but jam-packed film was an iffy choice I
liked how they set things up for the
future I'm really excited for the future
of this character but this movie was
jam-packed like the amazing spider-man 2
jam-packed like a lot is happening here
it's her whole origin story her whole
losing her memory and then
fish-out-of-water coming back and
getting her memory and fighting the bad
guys and learning her powers and friends
and enemies and cats because of that I
think it feels a bit like it's just
going from one thing to the next thing
to the next thing and you're it all it
makes sense the pacing is is really well
done I think but in that it's just
looking a little too much - and I really
really wish it could have been done in
two movies where we get her best friend
and we get like a really good
relationship with her and her best
friend and we get a lot of footage from
her past with who don't get in this
movie at all I think that would have
been really cool and I liked building up
her team that she's fighting with in the
beginning of this film and I just some
more background with the character
building I think something that really
helps this feel more grounded with the
characters is Fury's character Nick Fury
who just my god samuel l.jackson crushed
it in this film and also the cgi face
young inning
you heard me face young inning that they
did was amazing he looked so young so
good and the chemistry between him and
brie Larson were really really really
good was really really really good
who really really really good I also
before going into some specifics no
spoilers though I also will say that I
was in a jam packed audience I went to a
6:00 p.m. showing and the theater that I
go to only ever has 7 p.m. showings for
the new films and I paid extra and it
came with this Captain Marvel
opening night fan event coin I never
know what to do with these kind of
things it's cool I wish it were a pin
and not just like a coin I lost it ok
but my theater was packed and the
excitement about the movie was palpable
it was an energetic audience who was
laughing throughout applauding
throughout whispering to each other
about who they were seeing on screen
throughout really really fun audience to
watch this with and that's huge
it really skews how I feel about a movie
I'm trying to be really really fair
because I don't want this to there's
been a lot of weird things about this
online yeah it's just so weird I'm
trying to come out this from a very
neutral point and be honest with myself
and you guys but I really I really enjoy
this movie it was very fun there was
comedy throughout which was really good
but it wasn't about the comedy it wasn't
like a guardians of the galaxy or thor
ragnarok
it was a grounded important story that
because of these characters being
grounded and like being in these crazy
situations was funny the basic premise
is the Captain Marvel is in a band of
alien fighters in a war and they're
fighting more alien another race of
alien fighters and the other race of
alien fighters or shapeshifters and they
use the shape-shifting in a really
really good way and they use it a lot
and it's creative and it's fun probably
the most memorable part of the trailer
for me I'm definitely definitely
definitely the most memorable men mama
mama-mama ma-ma-ma-ma-ma
from Sponge Bob okay
tangent over let's get in here a lot of
people were worried about brie Larson
playing Carol playing Captain Marvel and
I think the one person who really shone
out as onyx
you know to me was Jude Law's character
and that was I think completely on the
writing I just didn't care at all about
the stakes of that portion of the story
at all at all it just like the little
group that he was in she starts in and
it just unexceptional I think is the
word that I'll keep using there's a
really cool and funny kind of Western
omage at the end goose the cat was
awesome
not many fighting scenes but again I
think the ending sequence was was cool
if maybe a little rushed the biggest
flaw of this film for me was definitely
that there was just too much happening
and not enough character building in
certain instances I really really really
loved the stuff between her and her best
friend and I loved the stuff between her
and fury and I loved the stuff between
fury and anyone else fury and goose oh
my god but if they would have just I
don't know a movie and a half instead of
a movie or two movies system one movie
is the one the biggest thing to me
though I found myself really enjoying
the whole thing and again I think Nick
Fury really helped with the character
building because we already knew him
it's like this anchor that we could kind
of grasp onto I enjoyed it but I tend to
enjoy things other people don't love
last Jedi it's funny people get way less
upset if you don't like something that
they like then when you like something
that they don't like on the internet you
would think it'd be switched but it's
it's definitely not it people get so mad
when you like something that they don't
like so I'm sorry I mean I'm not I'm not
truly sorry if I don't really good time
I hope you do too and and hopefully this
is a good jumping-off point for future
Marvel movies for infinity war 2 4 for
Captain Marvel 2 for the future of
Marvel movies I think that the
negativity that I was hearing from
certain outlets just I me personally
don't feel so if you're going into it
like I really want to like this but I'm
hearing bad things or like I'm don't
think I'm gonna like this I'm hearing
terrible things I don't know I I
we enjoyed it so that's enough talking
in circles I get really nervous for
things like this I went into last Jedi
Tamra just saw episode and I hadn't read
anything not like much and was just
blown away and so now every time this
happens I'm just like and I I'd like to
kind of kinda like it
Oh God okay I would give this seven out
of ten hair flips what should I see next
week wonder park the aftermath the
Mustang five feet apart or captive state
I've only heard of wonder Park and I've
seen that trailer like 7,000 times what
can I see something else please let me
know but you both ear thank you so much
for watching let's be honest we're all
just looking forward to the week after
with us Oh goose duck I have nothing to
prove to you
[Music]
you